بلغه فرق تسد الولايات المتحده تضغط على
ايران لوقف تحالفها مع روسيا ولمواجهه
روسيا فنلندا تملا احشاء مخازنها بالاسلحه
فما الذي يجري واوكرانيا تصرخ بالم نواجه
صعوبه بالغه في مواجهه جيش بوتين
الم نحدثكم من قبل البيت الابيض يترك
ليتوانيا في وضع لا تحسد عليه وامريكا
تعطي اسرائيل الضوء الاخضر يا ساده بينما
تلهث واشنطن وراء جنديها في كوريا
الشماليه وكم يجيب برد صادم وشد وجذب بين
الايكوس والنيجر وشراره المعارك تندلع
اوكرانيا تغرق في صعوبه المهارك تاره تغرد
خارج السرب وتعلن التقدم في احدى المناطق
وطارات تعلن التراجع الى الوراء وفقدان
بعض مما لديها وتاره اخرى تمد يدها للغرب
لطلب المساعدات وهذا هو الحال الاوكراني
باختصار يا ساده وهنا اعلنت اوكرانيا امام
الملا نحن نواجه اوضاعا صعبه للغايه خلال
مواجهات مع الجيش الروسي في محيط باخماط
والعهده على المصدر الذي تجدونه امامكم
فلا شيء ناتي به من رؤوسنا تحدث ايضا بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم وتكثف من
عملياتها الهجوميه في المحور الجنوبي من
مدينه باخموت ولكن الوضع معقد وصعب على
العكس لياتي الرد الروسي من نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي بقوله
الغربه غير مهتم بالمفاوضات حول التسويه
في اوكرانيا ويسعى لكسب المال من الحرب
لمجمعه العسكري وكانه يقول لاوكرانيا الم
نحدثكم من قبل ونكرر الحديث ذاته وكما
قالها
فالغرب سيقاتل حتى اخر جنديا اوكراني وهنا
تتجلى صعوبه المقاومه الاوكرانيه حيث
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بان القوه
الروسيه شنت عمليات هجوميه ناجحه وقضت على
890 جنديا اوكرانيا في كافه المحاور فعن
اي اعداد نتحدث وكالعاده لابد من مصدر
وكما تشاهدونه الان في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه لتوجه اوكرانيا ازمه من
نوع اخر وهي ازمه البطون الخاويه فمن لم
يمت في الحرب ما تجوعا وبعد ان باتت كيا
تستخدم الموانئ البديله اثرا انسحاب موسكو
من اتفاق الحبوب والممر المؤقت جدد ت
روسيا ضرباتها على ميناء اي اسماعيل وريني
في نهر الدانوب وهو ما اوقع اضرارا بمخازن
للحبوب
وهي الاوكران اتلفت الكثير من الحبوب
وتهددهم بالجوع وبالرغم من تلك الهجمات
فقد قال وزير البنيه التحتيه الاوكراني ان
السفينه تحمل
انطلقت عبر الممر الانساني الذي حددته
كياب خارج اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب لتصبح اول
سفينه تبحر عبر هذا الممر المؤقت الذي
انشئ للسفن المدنيه من والى موانئ البحر
الاسود فهل يخرج هذا الممر اوكرانيا من
حصار موسكو الخانق على صادرات البحر
الاسود
الى ميدان المعارك في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمر
قاعده للمدفعيه الاوكرانيه في منطقه
زابوريجيا باستخدام مسيره روسيه من طراز
لانسات واشارت الوزاره ان القوات الروسيه
استهدفت ايضا مركزا للمراقبه في اتجاه
باخموت وفرقه مشاه بينما اعلنت كيا في
استعاده بلده اوريجين الواقعه على اطراف
دونات وهي اول بلده تستعيدها كييف منذ 27
من شهر يوليو الماضي لتعلن القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ان قوه الدفاع الاوكرانيه تعمل
بفعاليه على الجهه الجنوبيه مشيره الى تد
ميرها الس اطلاق صواريخ وشاحنه وقود ومحطه
طيران تابعه للقوات الروسيه وفي هذه
الاثناء قال المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان بلاده لن تتمكن من استلام
مقاتلات اف 16 من الحلفاء في فصلي الخريف
او الشتاء المقبلين مشددا على ضروره تعزيز
الدفاع الجوي بشكل فوري وهنا جاء الرد
الغربي مطمئنا لاوكرانيا هذه المره حيث
شدد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ينسس
طولتن بارد ان الحلف سيدعم اوكرانيا حتى
تنتصر في الحرب ضد روسيا على حد قوله واما
الولايات المتحده وكما ذكرت صحيفه
نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه بان واشنطن تضغط على
ايران للتوقف عن بيع طائره مسيره الى
روسيا في اطار مباحثات على تفاهم غير
مكتوب اوسع نطاق بين واشنطن وطهران فهل
تقبل ايران بالعرض الامريكي تاركه وراءها
الحليفه الروسي امرا غير منطقي ومن حرب
التحالفات الى معارك العقل والذكاء حيث
نجحت روسيا في كسب اكثر من مليار دولار من
تكاليف شحن النفط الى الهند وذلك عبر
التلاعب بسقف اسعار مجموعه السابع
واستخدام الاموال الزائده عن الشحن لتمويل
حربها على اوكرانيا وذلك حسب ما ذكرت
صحيفه
سعر الغربي لها ولكنها زادت من ثمن تكاليف
النقل والشحن بخطه ذكيه وماكره ويا دار ما
دخلت شر فليس هناك سقف سعر للشحن والنقل
لتدور بين الاحداث وتضعنا في البيت الابيض
والذي قال مناسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
فيه جون كيربي ان اداره البيت الابيض لا
ترى اي ضروره لنشر قوتها على الحدود
البيلاروسيه الليتوانيه وفي حال احتجنا
للقيام بذلك فسناخذ الامر على محمل الجد
وكانهم لا يرون مجموعه فكنر تصول وتجول
على تلك الحدود
الحكومه ليتوانيا اغلاق نقطتين حدوديتين
مع بيلاروسيا ردا على لجوء عناصر من
مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه اليها من
جهتها اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الفنلنديه انه
سيتم انشاء اكبر مخزن استراتيجيا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي لوسائل الاستجابه للازمه
والادويه في حال التهديدات الكيميائيه
والبايولوجيه والنوويه في فنلندا ولا سيما
تهديدات الروسيه وبين هذا وذاك ولمنع
هجمات الروسيه محتمله اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الولايات المتحده وافقت على
بيع منظومه ارو 3 الاسرائيليه للدفاع
الصاروخي لالمانيا واوضح انها ستكون
الصفقه الاكبر لاسرائيل حيث اشار الى ان
قيمتها تبلغ 3 مليارات ونصف المليار دولار
الاحداث والتطورات افادت واشنطن بانها
تواصل العمل على تامين عوده الجندي
الامريكي الذي انشق عبر الحدود الى
بيونغيانج رافضه جميع التصريحات التي
تطلقها كوريا الشماليه حيث كانت الوكاله
المركزيه للانباء في كوريا الشماليه افادت
بان الجندي الامريكي
الذي عبر حدود البلاد يرغب في طلب اللجوء
السياسي في اي دوله ثالثه اعلنت المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
من اجل استعاده النظام الدستوري في النيجر
عقب الانقلاب الذي اطاح بالرئيس محمد
بازون بينما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في النيجر
مقتل 17 جنديا واصابه اخرين في كمين نصبه
مسلحون لفرقه عسكريه قرب الحدود مع
بوركينا فاسو فهل كان الكمين باعاز من
الايكواس ام حلفائهم الفرنسيين اصابه 80
فلسطينيا بمواجهه في نابلس عقب اقتحام
مستوطنين قبر يوسف بحمايه الجيش
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]